there are courses different places you
can find a map of courses do is one of
you want to make some announcements
three announcements or three people want
to make it optional all right
we have announcements
all right
that
okay one of the things you'll note on
course works now is some sort of
questions
/ comments by me that I intend to post
each week that will be sort of broad
topics of what might be thought about it
through the conjunction of the text and
the lectures for vast week for that week
so these are I realized over the weekend
that there was a reasonably high
likelihood that a certain number people
have no idea what the world I'm talking
about in the lectures from relationship
to the text I wanted to actually put
something down in writing as to how to
think about the course on a weak web by
week basis so by the end of the course
you'll have a sort of complete
collection of this kind of thought so
the first entry is up there now relating
to topics that were discussed last week
and you might want to look at those
before the discussion section although I
know one section was already met all
right this week we come to a chapter of
the book that is proven to be extremely
problematic and was a subject of
substantial debate among the authors and
the publisher and that has been
substantially altered for the next
edition of the book it has four topics
it has one early China Celtic Europe
early Americas and what's the fourth
early India
hmm Nubia yes why are these things
thrown together they're in different
areas they do not have a clear-cut
synchronicity in their timing
they reflect pressures that arise within
the the teaching world having do with a
sense among certain user groups teachers
school systems and students that that
it's important how early in the book
you're mentioned so that if you are not
mentioned until chapter 12 then you must
be insignificant compared with groups
that are mentioned in chapter one and
the two most sensitive areas have to do
with with Africa and with the Western
Hemisphere so the the pressure is to to
push something about Africa other than
Egypt the Nile Valley or the lower Nile
Valley and something about the Western
Hemisphere into an early part of the
book because then you have us waged any
feelings that have to do with the sense
that if you are not among the first
groups mentions that you somehow do not
have a legitimate share in history this
has meant with substantial resistance
from certain teachers and say well why
are we studying two societies in South
America in Chapter two and then not
hitting South America again until let's
say chapter 11
it's the disjunction it's like some sort
of hideous jump-cut in a movie where you
know you're following a conversation
then suddenly in the middle of a volcano
and how did you get there and you just
don't know and so so in the next edition
of the book that section on the early
civilizations in South America will be
gone from this chapter instead it will
be linked to a single chapter dealing
with the pre-columbian Western
Hemisphere and that chapter will be
moved from where it is currently chapter
12 to being around Chapter five so we
know it's it is instructive actually to
to be a part of debates like this
because these are things that reveal the
sensitivity that that is embodied in the
notion of trying to tell to tell the
history of the world to the population
of the world of course if you are only
dealing with the old traditional
euro-american white person classroom
these issues do not arise and that is
the reason it is the the multicultural
environment of the United States that
has generated the pressure for world
history but that has not yet been
experienced in let's say Europe which is
becoming multicultural kicking and
screaming but isn't really there yet and
ultimately it it will relate to the to
the question kind of a utopian question
of is it possible to write a narrative
of world history that can be taught
everywhere in the world
this is a this is a tough question now
UNESCO has tackled it a couple of times
they said if you put together you know a
group of historians like 50 or 60 of
them all from different countries and
ask them to write chapters on their
specialties you'll end up with a history
of the world
well in a sense you do but you don't get
anything like an integrated history
world and you've spent you know five or
six volumes doing it
reducing that to a narrative that will
occupy let's say a thousand pages or a
majors the way textbooks do that is the
challenge and other question is can can
you do a book that then you can actually
use everywhere in the world no one has
has succeeded but in a sense no one has
really perceived the problem in the
sense but once you do then you get this
question of tokenism
of adequate coverage of priority and
mention and things of that sort I
remember when I put in early mentions of
Australia the publisher saying well we
can edit that out
I said now not really no Abel Tasman
discovered tasmanian sailed around
australia let's put that in because we
gives us Jesse and Australia there's a
question of ah
gay and lesbian people should they be in
the book and if so how and when and
within what sort of cultural context
there's absolutely no question that
women have to be in the book
and indeed the every time we have an
author's meeting for a new edition of
the publisher gets someone who big husky
woman takes in the back room and beat us
up with a rubber hose and say there have
to be more women more women more women
because the the mandate to increase and
intensify the coverage of women is is
powerful and legitimate but you don't
yet have the same sort of thing for gay
lesbian bi and transgender people
question is will we will we have this
right now in the book you're reading
that you'll find in two or three
chapters references to to gay and
lesbian experiences and I think every
sentence is one that I've written I
don't think any of my colleagues have
have agreed that this is a topic you
know that should be included
and yet it is this kind of interplay of
of interests that makes the shaping of
this kind of course is the sort of book
difficult but also makes it peculiarly
challenging the goal of the authors
remains to be to be you know fair and
balanced like Fox News to to cover the
world in a appropriately representative
that the de scream until on how to how
to accomplish that for the earliest
periods I have mentioned that one of the
in a sense there's there's someone earth
easier because you can group if you
don't know anything about people's you
can group them more easily and say like
let's take all the people who who have
big rocks that look like this and use
them to bash other rocks you could say
okay well that's Paleolithic and so we
can put them all together but pretty
soon you run out of that out of that
possibility so so the grouping of
peoples has been a a key thing
particularly for the earliest histories
and
it's a very sensitive thing everyone
knows that the grouping of history
according to two attributes associated
with the word race is totally and
legitimately discredited that nobody is
going to produce in a world history
textbook a map of skin colors or hair
shades or eye color or something like
that much less a map dividing the world
into those people who have round heads
as opposed to those who have long hence
despite the fact that any maker of men's
hats will tell you that long oval hats
is very different from it from the
ordinary hat so because these indices
sort of gross indices of somatic or
bodily difference we're seen to be not
to correlate with anything particularly
useful not to provide distinct
boundaries and to be susceptible of
gross distortion and misuse by people
who were who are basically racist but
then you have other differences for
example blood groups here you have if
you have you can have an a group or a b
group and the Oh group is actually the
absence of a or B or you can have the
combined a and B and these happen to
have a very specific geographical
divisions and unlike something like skin
color they don't have gradations in
other words you are this or that as
opposed to halfway between this and that
so people have tried to define what the
blood groups mean because the the
distributions are are broad there is one
hypothesis for example not widely
supported but it's been put forward that
the old blood group goes back to the
Paleolithic big-game hunting time and
it's basically relates to diet and to
the eating of a meat heavy diet and then
the a group supposedly is related to the
to the rise of Agriculture not any
particular agriculture except that it
represents a more vegetable oriented
diet and and we know there are changes
that come in with more vegetable
oriented diet for example tooth decay
you collect teeth of prehistoric people
and there is essentially no there are no
there are no cavities
prior to agriculture and then
agriculture comes in with it's very
heavy carbohydrate load on the diet and
tooth decay comes with it so one of the
marks that archaeologists can use of
dietary change just from the bones is a
look at the teeth and see whether they
have tooth decay but that that of course
it will vary you have people with good
teeth and people with bad teeth whereas
something like a blood group has this
distinction of having a specific
boundary so the a group is sometimes
associated with agriculture and the B
group becomes associated with
with dairy products in that in that
association and these are very very
hypothetical associations which you
don't have a a high level of convergence
on this a date can be assigned to the
rise of the a group or by this theory
which must be somewhere around the the
early Neolithic may be going back to
twelve thousand ten thousand BC or
before the president at least whereas
the B group would then come in somewhat
later because the ability to digest
lactose that's associated with the
consumption of dairy products is
considered to be not only associated
with the rise of milk producing herd
animals but also with a fairly late
development they were you did not
originally use milk from those animals
because everyone seems to think that
that if you can't digest milk properly
you're not going to drink milk so the
argument is this is the reason East Asia
has a tradition of not consuming milk
products because they don't consume milk
products in East Asia because they can't
digest milk products then you look at
current information you find the 30% of
the world's milk is sold in China they
cheat they suddenly learn how did I just
know products or do they take some sort
of lactase supplement or what but in
other words the inferences are pretty
weak on these things but it's been
attempting a and B obviously is for
people who who know
eat plants and drink milk I know it's a
very loose so you have blood groups any
of language families language families
again represent something in which you
have a fairly good you know system of
boundaries having to do with mutual
intelligibility you speak language or
you don't speak a language as a as a
mother tongue there is a temptation to
imagine that all language must come
roughly from the same place and that if
Homo sapiens sapiens the modern man as
we man and woman modern humans if they
emerge from Africa which is the current
thesis then the origin of language
should be in Africa but is that
supportable when you look at language
families and this has to do with how you
group the families the there are of
course thousands of languages in the
world but they group into families
according to whether they share
vocabulary and grammar and and syntax
and sounds the effort has been made to
to
accumulate languages into larger and
larger groups
Joseph greenberg was perhaps the most
celebrated linguist who tried to group
the world's languages and the families
there is a website that will post that
will give you a link to the maps that
arise from this sort of enterprise in
which you have all of the world's
languages grouped into 17 language
families so that for the Western
Hemisphere for example and this you know
it's fairly well accepted that you have
one language family for the Inuits and
the Aleutians in the very far north
presumably the latest people to enter
the Western Hemisphere prior to leave to
modern Europeans then you have a group
that's just south of them now primarily
in Western Canada who speak a languages
at the masculine languages that belong
to a separate language family and then
you have the hypothesis that all other
languages spoken in both North and South
America belong to one family even though
there are you know a last out there
about a zillion of them they break into
sub families but this has to do with
with underlying theories about waves of
settlement coming across the the bering
sea on ice or on exposed land of various
points in history so that the earliest
people come across and move south to
north and south america and they have a
some sort of original language some sort
of or language that then
diversifies then followed by those
people who are now in western canada
followed the pivi in which evolutions
for the for the old world things are a
little clearer up but there you have a
something a theory called the no strata
clang guaa Jerry that maintains and this
is from a word that basically is like no
Stros like us you know our language so
this is a language theory that draws
together virtually all of the languages
of of Europe and northern Asia that's a
north of China that draws together the
languages that we more generally divided
into turco Mongolian and indo-european
and afro-asiatic that's a the language
of North Africa and it says they're all
part of one well how how do you huddling
with come up with these sorts of
divisions and here you have some
radically different theories about how
you can do this kind of comparison the
the traditional way was to look was to
take pairs of languages and minutely
match
vocabulary and sentences syntax
constructions and to observe that there
are certain standard changes this is
most advanced probably for the
indo-european language family that
encompasses all of the languages of
Europe
northern India and Iran Armenia there
you know you would say well there are
certain changes that took place and you
can trace those changes for example one
of the earliest divisions in
indo-european languages where ever it
took place
was difference between this autumn and
the Kenton languages this is all based
on the word for 100 so that a sod of
language use that for the word for 100
or something like it and a kantam
language use that the word for 100 now
you'll note that the word 100 in English
isn't either one and so it doesn't
always work but in Persian which is a
sod of language the word for 100 is sad
and in Latin it's Kempton so it works
for a lot of languages and it seems to
have a geographical pattern to it
so this division arose out of historical
linguistics and different hypotheses as
to when this division took place and the
hypotheses are fairly fairly sound but
there was another approach
that was fundamentally a statistical
approach or quantitative approach it
said intent instead of taking picking
two languages comparing them
particularly given the thousands and
thousands of languages
let's take 300 languages in a given area
and compare them statistically and how
would you do that well various methods
were devised having to do with well do
they have common sounds do they have
common you know structures for
morphology for example languages certain
languages are agglutinative this is
particularly true of the Turco Mongol
family
in which you take a route and you add
suffixes to it and the suffixes go on
and on and on and on depending on how
much you want to say so that one of my
favorites was the old advertisement for
for coca-cola in Turkey back in the
1960s they said coca-cola and II that
means the best seven letter G dish and
that one word seven seven letter G dish
was based on the syllable Sarah meeting
cool and so it was you know the making
to become cool and you could stretch it
out and sometimes Turks will have
contests of how long a word they can
make by putting suffixes on it and you
think well that's very peculiar form and
then you discover that actually Japanese
has some similarities to to Turkish and
people who know Japanese finally
learning Turkish rail it fairly easy
vice-versa and so now people are many
linguists say that korean and japanese
actually have early relations to the to
these languages in North and Central
Asia Turkish of Mongolian ah but the
quantitative test or the statistical
test never has quite the density of
explanation or density of evidence as
the one-on-one comparison of two
languages you might through a
quantitative technique discover that
French and Italian and Spanish and
Romanian and Latin are all related but
if you study them one by one in
comparison you know exactly how they
really
and so the the quantitative approach
never has quite the the convincing
quality as the older historical
linguistics approach however it lends
itself to a science perhaps that has
gotten a certain amount of play on
linguistic areas and this is known as
glottal chronology that is to say the
chronology of language the advocates of
chronology who have recently been
encouraged by the hypotheses suggesting
that alterations in DNA occur at a
steady pace of the number of mutations
that occur over time will be
proportional at a fairly predictable
rate to the amount of time that's
elapsed you can say how long it has been
you look at you know what is the
difference between the DNA of a baboon
and of a human and the look at the
percentage difference you say well that
indicates so many years so many million
years since they divided well the guado
chronologist said the same thing happens
with language that language and they
said this before the DNA people came
along that language changes at a at a
regular rate and that if you discover
two languages that are related
you can measure the degree of difference
and you can calculate when they divided
simply by multiplying that degree of
difference by the you know by your
multiplier for how for what the rate of
change is and how would they do this
initially they started with a 200 word
vocabulary list eventually that was
supplanted by 100 word vocabulary lists
and these were words that involved the
most unchanging vocabulary aspects of
the language for example they were
pronouns he see it they were words for
family members mother father sister
brother they were words for colors they
were words for certain verbs certain
physical actions and they would say how
rapidly does a language generate a new
word for one of these No
you can look at
just leave a language and see that there
are changes over time in basic words
after a great deal of debate the the
closest approximation seems to be by
those people who believe in glottal
chronology that within a basic word list
that you get one word you've got four
words changing every thousand years and
when that that rate of change four words
per thousand years has been plugged into
the differences between European
languages and the dates hypothesized for
the separation of any two European
languages like the separation between
Latin and Spanish or between German and
Danish or something like that it works
out pretty well that you know the number
doesn't seem implausible on the other
hand nobody is able to apply that rate
of change anywhere else
in other words attempts to to show
whether the languages of chile differ in
a in this fashion from the languages
from the Native American languages of
California that is not that is not borne
fruit so glottal chronology is is a work
in progress but what it represents is a
is this effort that you have for the
earliest phase of history to account for
very broad differences in in the
peopling of the world the one that is
traditionally focused on of course is
agriculture particularly grain
agriculture and so what these are
efforts to get beyond that sort of
measure
uh to two other sorts of measures other
sorts of differences
Oh
the
I could talk about animals right now but
I don't think so I've had your Reba
matted
I have to resist the temptation always
to head for the donkey's okay so let me
instead talk about big stones if you
look at the stuff on the Olmecs and
having societies of early of the early
Americas for Egypt and Mesopotamia and
Greece Europe back in the time of the
Celts and even with the pre-celtic
population and certain other parts of
the world you find that seemingly the
farther you go back in time the bigger
the stones are used as if somehow it was
hard for people to discover that it was
easier to carry a small stone in a big
stone which shouldn't have been a hard
discovery now I'm going to present a
theory as to why big stones are so
common and I will link here big stones
with big piles of dirt or in China with
tamped for that say where you take a big
pile of dirt and you drop it down for a
few years to make it into sort of solid
walls or bounds of things without sorry
the the the common feature between the
big stones and the and the big piles of
dirt and the tamped earth
seems to me to be that they are highly
highly labor-intensive and that they
tend to be focused on a single place as
you go slightly later in time and you
get to using bricks or smaller stones
you have a greater likelihood so far as
I can see that the structures will be
dispersed rather than concentrated in a
single place
so the as you move to smaller stones you
get greater dispersal but for these big
stone things they tend to be
concentrated in a single single spot
they do not generally correlate with
pre-agricultural society in other words
nobody has really suggested that
foragers who are living by sort of
constant migration in a natural
environment where they are able to
collect enough food and vegetable animal
and vegetable material to support one
person for a square mile you don't seem
to have megalithic or large stone
structures left eye's correlation with
agriculture there may be a correlation
with grain agriculture that's something
that's you know worth worth getting into
now why would this happen
if you have a productive of a
substantial of foodstuffs that are
storable such as grain or for that
matter you know dried yams or manioc and
so forth but let's stick here with the
grain if you have a a substantial amount
of food stuff that is storable and that
is surplus beyond what you are going to
eat in a given season or save for the
next season then you have the temptation
of those people who are able to steal
the surplus from everyone else that's
what we call taxation you know it's
associated with the rise of towns of
kingdoms and so forth that you have some
group of people who are bringing the
surplus together now how do you do that
here you have a village and it's growing
but they tweet and now you come to the
end of the harvest and somebody comes to
the village and says I'm from the
government and I'm going to take
one-third of all your wheat then the
people who village who are quivering in
fear say yeah go ahead take 1/3 of the
wheat we've hit in half of it anyway and
so then the guy says yeah well now you
have to carry it to where the King lives
because I can't carry it that's a lot of
wheat so you so that when you have large
quantities of stuff that are claimed by
people who
have the power to collect the surplus
whether it is olive oil or wine or grain
or whatever and we know fair about about
this because when all these things are
brought together in storehouses this is
one of the main reasons for the
invention of writing was to heat
notations of what was in the storehouse
to keep the store housekeeper from
selling it out the back door so you have
to bring all this stuff to one place all
right now you have a storehouse where
you have a whole lot of foodstuffs
because that's what's being produced
what do you do with them well you don't
have any money money isn't invented you
don't start to get coins or even pre
coinage uses of money until Oh 800 BC BC
something like that other words we're
talking about thousands years earlier
you don't have any money you don't have
any notion of a medium of exchange you
may have the notion of bartering but
there's always a question of you know
what will two bushels of grain get me in
terms of gallons of olive oil and it's
no so what you really have is one one
great collection of surplus that's
located in a particular place and what
can be done with it
of course the person who's collected the
surplus well there's a priest or a king
or a cast of warriors or whatever it is
they want to use that surplus for their
own
for their own purpose enjoyment
glorification or whatever but how much
grain can you eat I mean really a little
bit of oatmeal goes a long way and you
don't need to have a few thousand extra
bushels of grain so what you want to do
is to to exchange that grain for
something else of value but you don't
have a medium by which to do it you
don't have any money and the stuff is
real heavy and it just doesn't make
sense to to go to the village grab
everyone's surplus wheat carry to the
capital and then when you want something
carry it back to the village give it to
the villagers in return for something
else
and we change their mind we don't want
wheat we want Y now then you have to
carry the wine to the center so what you
want to do is to exchange this
accumulated surplus for something of
value that does not require you to carry
the stuff very far because you don't
have any wheels everything's being
carried on human backs maybe you have
some pack animals but but basically
you're carrying everything to one place
and you don't want to carry it back
again so what you want to do is to
substitute to use it in that one place
but you're not bartering it in the sense
that you have a market where you can
exchange this for that what you really
want to do is to use it for what it is
designed for for food so what you want
to do is to bring in all the surplus to
a single place and then feed a whole lot
of people at that place
that's your most efficient use of the
surplus I mean that you can have other
things you can know there may be a few
Goods brought in from foreign lands but
even then you're probably not going to
to exchange them in the earliest times
for heavy for heavy goods I mean if
somebody brings in gemstones from
Afghanistan to a kingdom in Iraq and
says here I have this beautiful
beautiful lapis lazuli stone from
Afghanistan and you say oh good I'll
give you 400 pounds of Queen you say
yeah when I'm walking back to
Afghanistan and I can't really carry
that with me now again you you don't
have a medium of exchange because you
don't have any any money so the best
thing you can do is to think of a labour
intensive product projects particularly
ones that are very very costly in terms
of labor that bring in thousands of
people and keep them there for a long
time namely moving big stones around
where you you know you don't care how
rapidly the building gets built if it's
a pyramid or a temple like that because
this is you this is your most feasible
use for this huge accumulation of
foodstuffs that you keep replenishing
every year so ah no forced labor by
humans becomes a compliment to the to
the seizure of the surplus by some sort
of dominant power structure
and the logic of the situation is that
you should be using that forced labor in
a single place warehouse or you are you
can warehouse your accumulated surplus
so by all means build a pyramid or build
a temple or build a really really really
big pile of dirt to put on top say of
the tomb of your king or something of
that sort because you don't you don't
want to do it quickly you want to
actually occupy thousands of people for
scores of years that is your best use of
the money I are the storage food I
feeling I sound a little bit like Burn
Notice and saying what a spy does is
this I mean this is not the only
possible hypothesis I'm not saying that
that all ruling elites have to do this
for example we know archaeologically
that that among the Incas in Peru you
have a period when they bring the
storage to more or less do a single
places and then other times when they
have warehouses are built along routes
and are used for the army so you say
well we we collect all the food at this
point not so we can you get labor but in
order to feed the army when we send the
army on conquest so you have other
models and this something archaeologists
can look into where where do you have
storage sites at a different period of
time but some of the most important
particularly of the proto literate sites
in Iraq in in Greece are these places
where you also have large stone
construction now apply apply big stones
why not have it be these smaller stones
or for that matter
why hampt earth instead of stones well
this has to do with how you move a big
stone and one of the important things is
these big stone cultures are prior to
the development of draught animals you
know you have oxen start to be used for
draught maybe Oh 5,000 6,000 BC horses
come somewhere around through maybe
3,500 BC that's about the same time the
camels come on line for for draught
purposes in Central Asia
so the draught animals are not there at
the very earliest phase of domestication
but rather using animals for pulling
things is discovering more more slowly
but once it is discovered gradually it's
discovered that you can adapt these
animals to to pulling not just a plough
or something but things that are very
heavy or compared Li heavy if you go for
example to the Egyptian Museum in Cairo
and you look at the or to the
Metropolitan and you look at very heavy
- you know tombs containers for for
mummy cases that built out of stone and
you look at you say well that must weigh
several tons if you look at the bottom
you'll find that the it seems to be on
stone runners that turn up at one end as
if they're meant to be pulled like a
sled and they probably were
but when you use animals to pull it's
very different from using people to pull
you can you can have a hundred people
pulling on ropes to move a large object
and we have pictures from ancient
Mesopotamia and Egypt showing hundreds
of people pulling on roads and and you
can have one guy up there the loud
voices says one two three pull and then
everyone pulls and they've moved the
obelisk six inches then one does we pull
it's another six inches and eventually
they get it the thirty two miles I have
to go in order to put it where the king
wants it but if you you know if you say
let's say one oxen is worth eight men
pulling on a rope so you can divide the
number of people pulling let's say at
eight hundred people pulling now you can
say just have builders have one hundred
oxen you can't say to the oxen one two
three pull because they don't know what
you're talking about and getting animals
that are not harnessed in a single team
to pull at the same time is a difficult
process it's easier to break your loads
into the sizes that is most convenient
for the animals to pull maybe you can
harness to animals or for animals or six
or eight animals but you can't harness
as many as you can with the humans so
when you have the harnessing of animals
the size the average size of the stones
goes down and it moves closer to what is
achievable by a harnessing the group of
animals even better
you have your bricks bricks are great
because bricks are modular and you can
divide them into the number of bricks
that can be pulled by by an animal or at
a later point that can be carried in a
wheeled vehicle all right so what I'm
saying is that in early societies but
say in the earliest societies the labor
that the energy that is available to
profile the energy profile Society is
basically that of of human muscles at a
certain point there is a important
subcategory that has to do with using
the wind to move vessels on water and
the history it into a history of sail
design at some point later there are
seem to be at least three different
parts of the world that have independent
traditions of sail design but let's
stick with the ground you start with
people who are whose the energy profile
is the individual person and in foraging
situations you simply don't have that
many adults who are available to to do
things if you have a a camping group of
50 or 100 let's say a third of them are
adult males you only have about thirty
guys and you know six of them are weak
and you don't like some of the others
and so it just don't have enough to use
a lot of collective labor so you get an
energy shift when you have density of
population that allows you to aggregate
more human muscle power that's a shift
of the energy profile it's not a shift
in the nature of the energy because the
energy is still human muscle and the
human muscle is fueled by consumption of
food but it's the ability to to to
govern and direct the energy that is
a question then you have a transition
that has to do with with the first draft
animals where you're now using animal
energy rather than human energy those
still dependent upon food and you are
dragging things then you move to
two-wheeled things perhaps and again you
have a shift in an energy profile so
you're using a lot of animal power
you're still using muscle power for a
lot of things human muscle power but
you're increasingly using animal power
now I mention this because it's going to
come back pretty much through this
little course that the energy profile of
a society even though you will not find
any theoretical work written on this at
a general level the energy profile of
society is a very crucial variable that
is not subject in particular to
religious cultural matters but sticks
pretty much to the physical realm when a
society shifts from one energy profile
to another energy profile there may be
various concomitant shifts that is to
say a certain form of energy may require
a different political structure or
economic or social structure or labor
structure in order to to utilize it and
so when you shift from one to another
you even though you might see it
primarily as a political social shift
underlying it is a is an economic and
technological change
it's important to distinguish between
this notion of energy profiles and
something like the Marxist notion of
mode of production in mode of production
where you go from from primitive
communism to up all the way through
feudalism and capitalism and socialism
and so on there you're talking
fundamentally about social profiles that
are correlate with different types of of
economic production and you get a
struggle between different social social
classes but the idea of energy profiles
sticks more to the to the technological
side of it historians who spend a lot of
time looking at mode of production and
the class struggles and developments
that are related to it tend to minimize
the technical side of it in other words
you might say that the Industrial
Revolution
you know depended upon you know certain
machines that were developed by certain
people but a mode of production analysis
will focus on the structure of capital
and labor that derives for those
machines rather than upon the machines
themselves as an energy profile approach
looks more at the at the technical side
of it let me give you an example from
from our experience today
if you seek out books on the history of
electricity of which there are some
extremely good ones you know
prize-winning books on the history of
electrical generation and electrical
systems most of them dealing with the
rise of electrical industries in America
Britain or Europe what you find is that
the what is seen as the crucial issue is
how much electricity you can generate
and how you can distribute that
electricity so you have this huge
competition in the United States between
Thomas Edison who believed in direct
current and his adversaries who believed
in alternating current direct current
cannot be changed by transformer to a
higher voltage so you the direct current
as it moves through the wire loses
energy through resistance at a fairly
high rate so what Edison visualized for
a city like New York was that you would
have an electric company every 15 or 20
blocks
it'd be more common than men's rooms
because the direct current simply would
not carry more than a few blocks before
the resistance in the copper wire was
such that it no longer would run the
machines it was supposed to run an
Edison was dedicated to to direct
current the the opposition said no
alternating current that can be stepped
up through a transformer can be sent at
a high voltage and as the voltage goes
up the amount of resistance does not
therefore the amount of electricity that
can move in a high voltage wire is not
at a significantly reduced by the
resistance in the wire and the first big
effort of course was the Agra Falls
where you had a alternating current
generator that then a distributed
electricity over a wide area through
high-voltage lines so instead of having
a Electric Company every few blocks the
way edison visualized the ordering
current said well instead we'll have a
landscape in which you have high-voltage
pylons marching across the landscape
throughout the land which is what we
have circa 1900 these would have seemed
like sort of matching absurdities you
know who's going to know huge pylons and
so forth
but that's the history of of electrical
generation and it's carried through by
other people who write about
hydroelectric projects and huge the
building of huge dams who write about
the development of nuclear power plants
it's over and so on so we have what I
call big electricity that is a profile
it gets structures the economy it
structures living patterns it structures
environmental Givens
unfortunately it structures all sorts of
things and so we think of the history of
electricity and we write it it's the
history of big electricity today every
one of you has somewhere on your person
something that uses small electricity in
fact infinitesimal electricity whether
it is you know well whatever it is for
most of you it's something like that and
it has a battery in it the history of
small electricity has never been written
but it has transformed the world as much
as big electricity because unlike big
electricity the the the capital
investment in physical plant is very
small so we've had societies that have
bypassed the heroic effort to lay copper
wire over millions of miles and have
gone directly to mobile phones and to
Wi-Fi and satellite stuff and so forth
and so on in which the end user is
relying on batteries that are very very
low voltage of batteries now when you
look at the history of trisomy you say
where's the book on on small electricity
you don't find it it's not a heroic saga
it isn't like the building of hoover dam
or
the struggle between electing current
and direct current it's something that
has become ubiquitous so that you can
pick up your double-a or triple-a
batteries pretty much anywhere you are
in the world which you cannot do with
big electricity you have countries that
are very very limited in their
electrical generating capacity and yet
have tons and tons of cellphones I don't
know how many of you know where double-a
and triple-a batteries are made China
and Japan are probably the two biggest
ones at least for the ones that are sold
in this country but
you know here we are we're dependent
batteries and we're not we're not making
them however we're really concerned
about generating huge quantities
electricity by nuclear or coal or
something like that by suggesting is
that when you shift to an energy profile
of small electricity it changes the
political context that changes the
social context changes the capital
investment pattern
it changes the geography and it changes
the environment because even though we
have little disposal boxes for your old
batteries here and there
ultimately we're just going to have a
zillion batteries around the world that
are leaking hideous toxins into the
environment and we'll say what it what
do we do with these batteries anyway
let's try this course I'm going to be
calling upon this notion of changing
energy profiles because the question
that that that interests me is why does
the society change from one to another
you know why did people think to use
animals to pull something instead of
just pulling it themselves it's not very
obvious you know you look at a cow you
think I bet he could pull something and
then you go and it's a wild animal or
semi wild animal and you think well how
are they going to pull it well maybe I
can tie it to his tail nope that was a
bad idea maybe and tie it to his horns
maybe I can do this maybe into that
these ships are are not intuitive
they're not self-evident
and yet they're often approached in
world history as if they are natural
progressions as this you move from one
to another to another and then when you
see a society that didn't make the move
then that becomes a questionable Society
so you look at the at the Western
Hemisphere and you say oops no wheels
and in fact you know they didn't know
how to harness animals and in fact they
didn't have any animals to harness oh
it's not really true in one of the
interesting things is that 10:00 they
had dogs they use dogs use dogs to pull
two sticks a travel ah that you could
load things on but even beyond that
where do they use dogs in the far north
using dogs to pull sleds large numbers
of dogs effectively harnessed to the
same task why didn't they use dogs
elsewhere because we have archaeological
evidence that the use of dog teams to
pull sleds in the Arctic precedes the
arrival of Europeans modern Europeans in
the Americas so you can't say that they
didn't that they couldn't have used
animal power even though dogs were their
only animal all you can say is they
didn't so you look at the energy profile
and you say well what are the what are
the pluses and what are the minuses here
why would that transition not have taken
place
the reason the Western Hemisphere
provides such a striking comparison is
that even though it does not go back
quite as far as the Olmec and the chim
you have some very early examples of
figurines animal figurines in particular
that have wheels
this has been a real mystery for so many
people I don't know why I say well if if
you could make a toy horse and put it on
wheels so you know tchan tchan tchan
tchan tchan
enroll your toy horse round why couldn't
you make a wagon and you know how could
you have discovered the idea of the
wheel and not have discovered the
functionality of the wheel and of course
the answers are not not all evident I
mean there are answers that say well
Native Americans were stupid or they
were stoned all the time or they were so
intrigued by you know human sacrifice
and whoa now all sorts of worthless sort
of racial elderly pieces use but it it's
a very interesting thing because it
addresses a question of why do you ever
have wheels the wheel was a really bad
invention
if primarily because it didn't work
what kind of what would you expect in
this sort of energy profile model to be
the first manifestation of wield the use
of the wheel of both wheel for
transportation wheel transport what
would you expect yeah a wheelbarrow
absolutely there are no wheelbarrows in
the ancient world you say well a wheel
why is a wheelbarrow preferred because
only has one wheel so the friction that
you have in having this wheel grinding
around an axle
you only have one as soon as you have
two then you have the problem of
supposing the friction is different on
one side another like that that chopping
card in which one wheel doesn't work and
you're pushing and you just hate it
because one wheel isn't turning right
but with the wheelbarrow you just have
the one wheel and yet there are no
ancient wheelbarrows and indeed for most
of ancient history down the medieval
period you don't have wheelbarrows
wheelbarrows are a great development in
China China is the great home of
wheelbarrow making and it's intriguing
because when you look at ah at a
wheelbarrow you say well this is a
pretty bad design because it's a lever
in which you have a fulcrum which is the
wheel and pressure and force which is
you lifting it and pushing it and the
weight is in between and you're really
carrying most of the weight when you
lift it why couldn't you have another
kind of lever for example in which the
weight is balanced on top of the wheel
instead of being between the operator
and the wheel so you have to spend so
much time lifting
the Chinese did this they developed
wheelbarrows where the weight is
directly over the wheel and we have
pictures you know you can see even
passenger vehicles where you have one
person sitting to the right of the wheel
one sitting to the left of the wheel and
one guy behind pushing the Chinese
developed wheelbarrows with sales so
that as long and once you you got the
thing up if you had a good wind
you just roll along and the wind blew
your wheelbarrow along but no
wheelbarrows in the West the reason you
don't have a wheelbarrow as the first
wheeled vehicle is because there is too
much friction
the earliest wheels couldn't be operated
by hit muscle power so that the energy
profile shift that goes from human
muscle power to animal muscle power
enables the development of wheels
because it it it aggregates enough
enough energy in the form of a team of
oxen to get over the threshold of
immobility that existed if you try to to
use a wheel ground now I know
Flintstones comedies will disprove all
of this but I'm trying to stick here to
a more more credible version of things
I'm going to to stop here but I'm going
to pick up on wheels on Thursday because
the some of the societies we're dealing
with in this in this chapter have very
important uses of wheels the kelps for
example and the Zhong Chinese so I will
pick up on wheels on
Thursday meanwhile everyone who is not
registered for a section please go and
talk to Owen